[Music]
we'll look you tease the brow and a fail
just ignore them they're trying to get
under your skin
oh how cute is there Dennis look at him
they're like close it in his eyebrows
looks like boogie cousins as a boogie
brother I don't know though I'm a bit
scared I mean with this chemistry
they've got I think they've got a real
shot at the tint see you know you talk a
lot for someone who has less rebounds at
its point God Marcus if you get a
technical you'll be suspended again I'm
sorry
we're being rude I am actually a big
admirer of your game I love the move
where you fake left roll right and then
get dejected you know for being a big
whiny lose all that fancy little stash
so far and your throat you uh get on
your it's right enough of this king of
the frame of the proof while we're
bickering over eyebrows and mustaches
Golden State is marching towards the
championship save your energy for the
real fight five became regretful what
disembowelment of a referee which the
league is sort of cracking down on now
do you like it here in Dallas
very much so better than Golden State
Golden State is a very special place
dear to my heart
but I'm very happy here in my new home
but don't you miss being a contender I
have a much larger role here thanks to
the graciousness of our Lord I almost
didn't recognize you without your
cylindrical hair it is an honor to
present my King Lord mark of House
Mavericks kiss me child Thank You
Harrison we're delighted to have you
here please sit
would you like a rib no thank you I'm
not very hungry
Oh child you can't come to Texas and not
enjoy some barbecue okay
you like their ribs it's very good there
Chandler Parsons favorite thing to eat
when he was here oh you must be thirsty
where's the sweet where's the sweet tea
but don't just stand there you imbecile
get up Sam sweetie now I know things
were difficult for you in Philadelphia
I'm very grateful for my house stop it
it's dreadful in that chamber part of a
franchise now come on you can be honest
with me I'm not like those other owners
you know I'm a cool guy
just a normal cool guy noted well if I'm
being honest there were a lot of centers
and not enough minutes frankly I was
very sick of losing a child there's no
need to worry anymore here in Dallas we
never tank now chin up aren't you
excited to play with Dirk oh yes he's
very good he's the greatest yeah he's
great the great test the greatest you
see Nerlens i personally ensure that no
one makes light of my mavericks
for else or else what
ah my sweetie